[Applause]
thank you thank you yes so stop it stop
it you bad people
well
thanks for stopping by
happy Wednesday everyone so we all
remember that letter Politico published
ahead of the 2020 election that
dismissed the hunter laptop story as
Russian dis info by the way when I say
we all remember I obviously don't
include the president
the letter was crafted right after the
New York Post had published a piece on
the laptop which Hunter had dropped off
at a computer repair shop and then
abandoned it like it was his child
it's true as a baby with a stripper
not that there's anything's wrong with
that no not at all
time whoops all right so anyway I know
the feeling my parents did that with me
at the highway rest stops and I made so
many new friends
that joke makes no sense and I don't
care the hard drive contained tons of
stuff concerning Biden's business
dealings as well as all sorts of sorted
or in cat's view romantic videos of
Hunter doing drugs and hookers and not
always in that order
but then miraculously this letter signed
by 50 odd Intel experts appeared to save
Joe's day and the boy did it the story
was blacklisted by Major media outlets
and social media algorithms they've even
mentioned it you were mocked scorned or
suspended from Tech platforms I like
getting suspended from things but not
Tech platforms
you know what I mean the rest is history
Trump lost and now we have this
you know thank you for joining us as
well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right it reminds me of those late
night commercials with sad dogs
[Laughter]
those are all stunt dogs by the way but
in Casey croaks then we're stuck with
this
remember Venn diagrams those three
circles Venn diagrams Venn diagram Venn
diagram Venn diagram I love Venn
diagrams I really love Venn diagrams you
know the circles right three usually
her Venn diagram is stupid and really
stupid
since then of course the laptop story in
the New York Post have been Vindicated
but like Joe Biden sphincter it was too
late
I don't even know what that means but we
had to wonder how did that letter come
about why were so-called Intel experts
so happy to dismiss something they
didn't bother to investigate well last
night Brett Baird the host of Special
Report and also my personal masseuse
I actually had one of the letter
endorsers on his show a former CIA
officer it was a great get for Brett but
only because Angela Lansbury was a
no-show
[Music]
R.I.P
[Laughter]
but this was hilarious
October days before the 2020 election
you signed on to this open letter that
was published by Politico it said we
write to say that the arrival on the U.S
political scene of emails purportedly
belonging to Vice President Biden's son
Hunter much of it related to his time
serving on the board of the Ukrainian
gas company verismum has all the classic
earmarks of a Russian information
operation right why did you sign on to
that yeah because of what it says it has
all the classic earmarks of one of these
operations you'll note elsewhere in the
letter if you read it that it also says
we don't know if this is a Russian
operation at all so get this it had all
the classic earmarks
but it's not like we said it's real
because we don't know right okay since
when do 50 members of intelligence
suddenly put out an urgent letter saying
we don't know when does that ever happen
sorry dude 50 people don't do anything
urgently if they have misgivings I mean
they acted like they all got food
poisoning from the same Chipotle and
we're racing to find a toilet
otherwise when people aren't sure or
they're ambivalent what's the rush
where's the fire you do nothing bear
points out that even though the agent
claimed they didn't know Biden still
used it exactly the way the agents had
intended there are 50 former National
Intelligence folks who said that what
this he's accusing me of is a Russian
plan you mean the laptop is now another
Russia Russia Russia hoax that's exactly
what this is exactly what this is so
understanding how you characterize it
but he characterized it differently and
used it in a debate just days before an
election yeah I'll let President Biden
speak for himself he's capable of doing
that oh he is
give us
give us one example that's like saying
I'll let Kermit the Frog speak for
himself after Jim Henson died
Joe only speaks if you feed him the
words like he did in this phony letter
but my favorite part is this
people who study Russian disinformation
Intelligence Officers who look at
Russian tactics over the long period of
time this is the kind of thing they like
to amplify to sow Discord within Target
countries
you get that it's Russian disinformation
even though the information is true
because they amplify it that's like
being caught in an affair and saying
yeah it's true but bringing it up makes
it false so please don't
that's what I use
but at least he didn't keep repeating
himself it has all the classic ear marks
of a Russian campaign it has all the
Classic earmarks this has all the
classic earmarks of a Russian
information campaign has all the classic
earmarks of a Russian information
campaign it's like you say Beetlejuice
hoping that Lori Lightfoot arrives to
rescue him
yes
yes then he blames the media and anyone
else he can find
in the way it was disseminated and
propagated through media says no it
wasn't true no I had the class of year
marks but it wasn't true
what is not true that it was Russian
disinformation that's not what we said
in the letter read the actual letter and
we said we do not know if this is
Russian disinformation it has all the
classic earmarks of a Russian
information operation exactly the
difference between an information
talking about a disinformation not yet
to candidate in a misinformation
campaign it's not my fault if people
don't look up definitions
um I'm sorry I was just looking up
psychopath
so it's our fault that we don't know the
difference do you believe this guy once
worked for an outfit that has the word
intelligence in it you know I'll agree
with him about the media they ran with
this letter but not the laptop like it
was the truth despite the laptop having
endless videos of Hunter Biden's butt
and other things
look how blurry it is
check check that
go to a doctor
anyway but that's exactly what they were
expected to do once a letter like this
from 50 experts gave them the cover they
needed it gets worse
he said it plainly on a debate stage
that obviously affected the dynamic
don't you think I would absolutely love
for all news media to show Nuance on all
these issues instead of racing to sound
bites dude there were no sound bites
they were the facts were taken from the
letter you co-wrote which again you was
the plan all along no one writes a
letter to be ignored like the ones I get
from Kill means lawyer all the time
yeah
so this is just a glimpse of who was
involved in this fraud now multiply this
dim width by 50. the ends justify the
means you can lie to the American people
and there's no consequences but that's
50 reasons why you got to go vote and
take control of the house because every
single signer of that letter needs to be
questioned just like that like who asked
them to do this were they paid did they
deduct that contribution from their
taxes but I credit this guy for at least
showing his face in public something I
wish Madonna would stop doing
but
bottom line they didn't know how to end
this
but the fact is we wouldn't let this
kind of crap slide in the workplace
listen Jerry the reason we called you in
here I don't understand why you've spent
950 on lap dances well I will admit
um it had all the classic earmarks of
the lap dance but I don't think legal
sent over a video from fat Tony's house
of hot ladies so we know what happened
it's true oh Define true you know like
it's true TV true or how about True
Detective I mean you really think
Matthew McConaughey was solving all
those Mysteries I mean listen just admit
it happened and we can all move on what
happened that night was I was at the
club okay and then these two bouncers
they come up to me we start doing just
shots left and right I'm up there at the
club they're like how many bills you got
big boy I'm like I got bills both days
cash money cash money and then they're
like they're offering me dances they
come up to me they get up in my face I'm
up on the table they're just gonna run
they're just going they get it all up in
my face they're giving me all the love
in conclusion uh it had all the classic
earmarks of a laugh dance you're fired
so like a like an earmark of a fiery
real firing
[Applause]
nice
yes she went from the NFL to giving
Lefty's Hell host of the sideline sanity
podcast Michelle Tafoya
he's known for his charity work
providing jobs for Jamie lissau
of the great new movie daddy daughter
trip Rob Schneider
sees like a Twizzler slim sweet and
twisted Fox News contributor cat tube
and to him the Grand Canyon is just an
okay Canyon my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Television Champion Pirates
Rob yes great to see you nice to see you
and I want Jamie listo back yes Adam
enough now he's come back he wants more
money I know I know he's been quailer
he's been very helpful here and what the
movie comes out next week this weekend
this weekend your daddy daughter trip
yeah it's it's now it's not an adult
film no no it's the daddy-daughter thing
it's very popular on PornHub
how do you know that nothing I just read
about it in a Wall Street Journal piece
this one's South quick hey came on here
to promote the movie
no but no idea is coming out in the
Cinemark thank you for having me yeah
awesome awesome congrats by the way I I
want you to know that I didn't wait
until you you know had the number one
show before I appeared but it just
seemed to work out that way
I understand I'd wait to see if this
monstrosity would sink or swim and it's
swimming still swimming yeah that's what
I think swimming is congrats thank you
thank you can I keep doing this yes does
this make you uncomfortable so what do
you make of this whole uh whatever I
just said this uh laptop and the stupid
letter I'm just amazed but at the
restraint and honor of those prostitutes
not coming forward
it's remarkable I mean if you if you you
really have to hand it to them their
integrity is more than the CIA guys
seriously yeah that great point because
who's talking they're not talking
they're not coming out they're not
coming they're really trustworthy well
they have to if you're if a hooker if a
hooker talks then she's not a hooker
[Laughter]
that's my that's what my grandfather
said yes
anyway we should probably move on you
know this went South quickly yes he's an
expert he did that great documentary as
I'm studying Pimp's life yeah he's got
he's got experience in that he was a
male gigolo that's right I still get
that yelled to me that's a huge [ __ ]
yes they'll get that
Michelle yes I apologize why do you
think the guy just admit it was all Bs I
think I have a reason he has to cover
for the other guys well here's the
here's the sentence that gave them cover
they said we want to emphasize that we
do not know if these emails are false
right they they say that in there but
then they go along to say but just that
our experience makes us deeply
suspicious that the Russian government
played a significant role in this case
and so there you go they they on the one
hand went out of their way as you said
to label this letter
you know 50 people talking about Russian
disinformation but but we're not saying
that it is it is but our deeply held
beliefs and by gosh you should believe
us because we have so much credibility I
it's it's just ridiculous I mean go what
you know I just said it's like it's like
my wife's driving it's like honey I
didn't say we were lost they said we
have all the ear marks that you went the
wrong direction
right right
it's true
so cat what is your take on this it
pisses me off right that guy can get on
Special Report and I can't
you're still gonna hold that against
Brax what did he do a good job no he did
no but it's always that's why I am
always really careful about like
trusting these intelligence guys because
they are able to get away with lying so
much more easily because I don't even
really have to lie if they're ever
questioned they're like oh well that's a
lot of sensitive information so they
don't have to explain it obviously not
there's some things that do need to be
kept secret uh there are you know
they're not saying they're always lying
but just based on how human behavior
works these are the exact people you
should be questioning the more you know
tools they have at their disposal to
hide stuff I wanted to tweet that at the
times 50 professional Liars This Is A
Lie
exactly and but you know what they all
came from one part of the CIA they
weren't like they all worked for
Democrat uh uh administrations I guess
so it was they were like they didn't ask
specific they didn't just do a broad
questionnaire why do we keep hearing new
words invented from yeah earmarks we're
all we're all just cool
it has all the ear narks yeah
my follow-up question would have been
what's an earmark I'd love to know
because my ears don't leave marks so I'm
just curious my fingers do because this
has all the Fingerprints of typical
Democrats is what it comes out to be
you could say anything any liar can say
anything and what he did was he said a
bunch of nothing could have been might
not have been not our fault could have
been our fault maybe our fault but
definitely our fault the president used
it to help win an election
not our fault yeah it has all the
earmarks yes so we need to take the word
earmark away and they just they
basically said we did it but we're
blaming it on Russia exactly hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else